[Música]
hola bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en el
que hacemos un recuento de las noticias
más destacadas a lo largo de las semanas
relacionadas con la pandemia del cob y
19 a continuación les presento algunos
de los temas que vamos a tratar en esta
edición vamos a hablar de los últimos
datos revelados dentro del escándalo
vacuna gate en perú cómo están avanzando
las investigaciones y cómo están
surgiendo más preguntas que respuestas
ahora la repartición de las dosis y la
cifra total no coincide con la cantidad
de dosis que han sido entregadas vamos a
conversar en minutos con nuestro
corresponsal en lima para conocer más
información allí en perú también esta
semana el salvador colombia venezuela y
la república dominicana comenzaron sus
planes de vacunación con nuestros
corresponsales vamos a conocer cómo
están avanzando las jornadas y vamos a
conocer los detalles de cómo son los
planes en cada país porque si bien el
fin es el mismo es decir inmunizar a los
ciudadanos la estrategia y la rapidez y
agilidad del plan varía en cada uno de
los países en minutos les vamos a contar
y chile es el país de américa latina que
está
la vacunación contra el hobbit 19 en
solo un par de semanas ya 2.3 millones
de personas fueron inoculadas a nivel
nacional incluida la remota isla de
pascua o rapa nui a más de 3.700 km de
la costa de chile este territorio no
presenta casos de kobe 19 gracias a una
particular estrategia que combina el
aislamiento con la sabiduría ancestral
conversamos con el alcalde de rapa nui
pedro edmunds paoa quien nos dará más
detalles de esta estrategia comenzamos
entonces en perú el escándalo del
denominado vacuna gate estalló esta
semana en este país y ha tenido
indignado a los ciudadanos peruanos
recordemos que 487 funcionarios del
estado también algunos de sus familiares
y algunas personas cercanas fueron
inoculadas de manera secreta antes de
que fuera activado el plan de vacunación
a nivel nacional las autoridades
pusieron en marcha una investigación que
ha dado a conocer los nombres de quienes
están en ese listado que fueron elegidos
de manera arbitraria y de manera
preferencial entre
vamos a conocer entonces más detalles
con francisco zacarías en la ciudad de
lima francisco muy buenas noches allí en
la capital peruana y cómo están
avanzando entonces las investigaciones y
que han podido establecer las
autoridades hasta el momento
muy buenas noches el escándalo es
investigado por cuatro entidades el
gobierno el congreso la fiscalía y la
contraloría precisamente esta última
establecido que en realidad son 470
personas repito 470 personas las que han
sido vacunadas clandestinamente y el
organismo ha establecido ha identificado
a 122 funcionarios públicos de los
ministerios de salud relaciones
exteriores y otras entidades del estado
que abusaron de su poder para ser
vacunados ellos y sus familiares o
algunos relacionados con ellos
precisamente el organismo en los está
investigando por haber sido vacunados
irregularmente y también está tratando a
establecer si la vacunación fue
determinante para que ellos se siguieran
por aprobar el contrato con la empresa
china sino farm esto ha indignado a los
peruanos porque mientras sucedían todos
estos hechos el sistema nacional de
disfunciones calculaba que más o menos
recién mil peruanos habrían fallecido
por el codo y 19 entre ellos 310 médicos
125 enfermeras y 525 policías este
escándalo es conocido como el vacuna
gate y eso sin principales implicados
son el presidente el ex presidente de
martín vizcarra la ex ministra de salud
patricia
masetti así como la excanciller
elizabeth astete y otros funcionarios
francisco entonces hago énfasis en que
son 470 esta actualización también se
habló en un momento de 500 personas 487
ya estamos en 470 como ha salpicado este
escándalo al gobierno del actual
presidente el presidente francisco
sagasti como está intentando desmarcarse
de esta situación para poder continuar y
avanzar en lo verdaderamente importante
que es la vacunación de los peruanos
el escándalo no solamente ha afectado
sino ha debilitado al gobierno del
presidente francisco sagasti
precisamente por ello ha organizado una
comisión investigadora que está siendo
dirigida por fernando carbone él es un
ex ministro de salud de una persona con
reconocido prestigio él ha señalado que
no solamente son 470 los que se han
vacunado sino también habría una segunda
lista con nombres y rostros que aún no
han sido conocidos él ha cruzado
información con diversas entidades del
estado y espera que el 25 de febrero se
dé a conocer la lista final y esto va a
ser este a través de una conferencia de
prensa precisamente sobre este escándalo
la primer ministra del gobierno peruano
ha señalado que el gobierno de sagasti
no descansará hasta que se sepa toda la
verdad
francisco hay algo que llama la atención
y es que las cuentas del número de dosis
que recibieron y el número de dosis
entregadas no coincide cuáles son las
hipótesis que están manejando allí
justamente las autoridades han
establecido que si no farm entregó en un
primer inicio además del material médico
para los ensayos clínicos 3200 dosis de
vacunas adicionales éstas son conocidas
como la vacuna de cortesía estas se
dividieron en dos mil dosis que
teóricamente iban a hacer para los
ensayos clínicos y un grupo fueron
entregadas los voluntarios otra los
funcionarios públicos pero también
existían 1.200 dosis de vacunas que
fueron entregadas directamente a la
embajada china la fiscalía no puede
hacer un interrogatorio a los
diplomáticos chinos porque el convenio
de viena no les da inmunidad entonces la
justicia peruana va a tratar de
establecer esto pero si china es el
principal socio comercial de perú y las
autoridades no quieren que el escándalo
les perjudique el trato comercial con
los chinos ni tampoco el contrato por
los 37 millones de dosis de vacuna que
todavía no llegan al país gracias
francisco por esta actualización en
torno a la vacuna gate y ya han empezado
a surgir otros en argentina ya está
sucediendo algo similar y seguramente lo
estaremos reportando acá en los próximos
días
así está avanzando entonces la
vacunación en américa latina' cada vez
más países están uniendo al grupo de
naciones que ya están vacunando a sus
ciudadanos veamos algunos datos
suministrados por ahora world in that a
eeuu 57 puntos 74 millones de dosis ya
han sido inoculadas le sigue brasil con
6 millones 200 mil dosis inoculadas
canadá 1.35 millones de dosis mientras
que argentina en el extremo sur del
continente ya superó las 635 mil dosis
de la vacuna es punible alli inoculadas
bolivia por su parte su mero sumó la ya
superó las 10 mil mientras que ecuador
llega a las 8 mil 190 dosis como lo
decíamos república dominicana que
comenzó esta semana lleva hasta el
momento 300 73 dosis inoculadas
y colombia el esperado plan de
vacunación comenzó tres días antes de lo
previsto pero este país es uno de los
últimos en sudamérica en iniciar su
campaña que busca inmunizar a 35
millones de personas es decir el 70 por
ciento de la población en el menor
tiempo posible con más de 2.2 millones
de casos y más de 58.000 personas
fallecidas colombia lucha contra el
tiempo para inmunizar a su población el
primer lote de 50.000 dosis de vacunas
de facer variante se sumarán también
otras 192 mil dosis que van a llegar de
china de la farmacéutica scinopharm esto
en los próximos días para alcanzar 1.6
millones de vacunas en unos cuantos
meses el presidente iván duque habló
sobre este tema escuchemos
hoy empieza un nuevo capítulo en lo que
es la derrota de esta pandemia
este capítulo empieza con la vacunación
masiva segura y eficaz y gratuita en el
territorio nacional vamos a ampliar la
información con federico cue barberena
desde la sala de redacción de france 24
allí en bogotá en colombia para darnos
más detalles hola federico en 1ª semana
de la puesta en marcha de este plan en
colombia como avanzado parece que va más
rápido de lo esperado
la vida con la llegada de las 50.000
dosis del fármaco de facer y variante
que si bien se adelantó su inicio al 17
de febrero en ese primer día sólo se
aplicaron 18 dosis entre sincelejo y
montería las dos ciudades de la región
caribe en las que comenzó la campaña el
contraste se dio al día siguiente con
unas 7.800 dosis aplicadas y según los
cálculos del ministerio de salud en
cuatro o cinco días podrían
administrarse la totalidad de las
inyecciones correspondientes a este
primer lote que llegó al país el titular
de esa cartera fernando ruiz es destacó
la capacidad demostrada por bogotá y
también las buenas experiencias que
sumaron en el departamento de antioquia
y en la ciudad de cartagena frente a las
críticas de quienes cuestionan la
lentitud del despliegue el ministro
reconocido que no es un proceso fácil
pero se mostró confiado en acelerar este
proceso en las próximas semanas
federico hubo mucha controversia en
colombia porque al momento de anunciar
este plan de vacunación al presidente se
le olvidó incluir el departamento de
amazonas que ha tenido muchos problemas
con la variante que llega de brasil
porque precisamente el fronterizo
hubo muchas controversias en torno a
otros temas que es lo que ha sucedido
allí
en un primer momento del departamento de
amazonas no apareció entre las zonas
elegidas para recibir vacunas algo que
según el gobierno se debió a un error
involuntario finalmente de este primer
lote de 50.000 vacunas a esa región le
corresponden sólo 54 dosis porque
letizia que es cabecera de este
departamento tiene dos instituciones de
salud que atienden casos de kobe tampoco
fue la única la única controversia en
torno a este inicio de la vacunación
desde algunos sectores por ejemplo se ha
criticado una excesiva burocracia en la
distribución de las dosis que provoca
que unas pocas vacunas lleguen a lugares
de compleja logística que podría
aprovecharse mejor mediante la
asignación de una mayor cantidad de
dosis
la otra gran crítica fue la alta
exposición de funcionarios del gobierno
en las jornadas iniciales de vacunación
pasando desde el presidente iván duque
por ministros que fueron asignados para
presenciar el comienzo de la vacunación
en la ciudad de cabecera y también
gobernadores y alcaldes incluso ocurrió
que en cali el comienzo de la
inmunización debió retrasarse 5 horas
para permitir la llegada del ministro de
justicia estos hechos fueron bastante
cuestionados sobre todo
en cuenta que estamos en vísperas de un
año electoral
federico los retos para este país son
enorme en 50 millones de habitantes
problemas de seguridad inmigrantes
venezolanos zonas de violencia grupos de
narcotráfico como maneja la situación
allí
la logística es un gran desafío para
colombia un país vasto de geografías muy
diversas y con poblaciones de difícil
acceso el clima es uno de los desafíos
en algunas zonas es de calor extremo lo
que supone un problema para la
conservación de los fármacos que suelen
necesitar de importantes cadenas de frío
colombia tiene una experiencia positiva
con el llamado programa ampliado de
inmunizaciones que cuenta con más de
3.100 lugares de atención en todo el
territorio este plan ha logrado buenos
resultados en la vacunación de
poblaciones de diferentes edades esto le
da un cierto tejido por el cual comenzar
pero el desafío de la pandemia luce
mucho mayor la cantidad de personas a
vacunar es más amplia a los tiempos son
escasos y los recursos deben ser
aprovechados al máximo una posibilidad
es incluir a las fuerzas armadas como un
actor más para reforzar la distribución
de las vacunas una posibilidad que no ha
sido descartada por el gobierno a esto
hay que sumarle que hay territorios en
conflictos donde la presencia de grupos
armados y la violencia pueden suponer un
obstáculo para la llegada de las vacunas
que sigue entonces en las fases
siguientes
plan de inoculación qué es lo que espera
el gobierno para los próximos meses
el gobierno de colombia sostiene que
mediante la negociación de diversos
contratos se se ha asegurado la cantidad
de vacunas necesarias para inmunizar al
70 por ciento de su población en 2021
por lo pronto tras este primer lote con
el que inició la vacunación el proceso
se aceleraría con 192 mil dosis de la
vacuna del laboratorio chino sinovac que
llegan este fin de semana y otra hace 50
mil dosis de facer que arribarían la
próxima semana el ministerio de salud
también estima a recibir unas 100 mil
dosis semanales para acelerar el ritmo
de la campaña la primera meta que se ha
trazado el gobierno en palabras propias
del presidente iván duque es administrar
el fármaco a un millón de personas en el
primer mes
cabe destacar que este plan inicia con
los trabajadores de salud y continuará
en el orden de prioridades a lo largo de
sus diferentes etapas con adultos
mayores y con las personas que tienen
condiciones preexistentes
gracias federico por este reporte desde
la sala de redacción de france 24 en
bogotá en colombia y cinco días después
de que recibieran las primeras 100 mil
dosis de la vacuna sputnik de venezuela
también comenzó la vacunación
ciudadanos llegó el momento llegó la
hora sí dijo la vicepresidenta del tsje
rodríguez al dar detalles de este plan
de vacunación este primer lote
representa solamente el 1% de un pedido
total de 10 millones de dosis que
caracas solicitó a moscú las autoridades
venezolanas indicaron que esperan para
el mes de abril ya comenzar el plan de
vacunación masivo a nivel nacional
informó al país que hoy iniciaremos a
vacunar
esta primera etapa
de salud en nuestra paz estábamos muy
abordando
la región capital caracas miranda lago
esta etapa que nos llevará dos semanas
se extenderá a todo el territorio
nacional más detalles sobre este tema en
caracas con herminia fernández nuestra
corresponsal allí en venezuela buenas
noches
herminia y cuál es el balance y los
detalles de esta primera semana de
vacunación en venezuela
si santiago oficialmente comenzó en
venezuela la vacunación el 18 de febrero
con la aplicación de las primeras dosis
de sputnik de trabajadores sanitarios en
hospitales de caracas miranda y vargas
la primera persona en ser vacunada fue
una doctora del hospital victorino
santaella del estado miranda esta
primera etapa de vacunación durará dos
semanas y se extenderá progresivamente a
todo el territorio nacional según el
ministro de salud carlos alvarado 60
hospitales centinelas en el país ya
cuentan con refrigeradores para el
almacenamiento de las vacunas por ahora
en miranda se prevé vacunar a 7000
trabajadores de primera línea mientras
que en caracas se aplicarán 11.000
trabajadores venezuela recibió las
primeras vacunas de sputnik
el pasado sábado 13 de febrero con la
llegada de 100.000 dosis la comisión
presidencial para el control y la
prevención de la cob y 19 ha planificado
el proceso de vacunación masiva para el
mes de abril
herminia han criticado mucho el gobierno
de venezuela por haberse demorado mucho
en adquirir estas vacunas que es lo que
dicen desde miraflores
el gobierno venezolano tiene unas
sanciones impuestas por eeuu y debido a
éstas la administración de maduro ha
señalado que se le está dificultando
obtener unos 300 millones de dólares que
tiene congelados en reino unido portugal
y españa- caracas se ha dirigido a la
organización de naciones unidas para que
liberen los fondos bloqueados por las
sanciones económicas que pesan en su
contra y así comenzar la vacunación
masiva de su población madura ha dicho
que las sanciones son acciones fuera de
marco de la legalidad internacional
fuera de la carta de la 1 y espera que
los sectores políticos de eeuu
reaccionen en estos momentos de pandemia
vemos que hay muy buen entendimiento
entre moscú y caracas cuanto ha
invertido entonces venezuela para poder
adquirir estas dosis necesarias de la
vacuna sputnik de fabricación rusa
de nicolás maduro ha asegurado que este
primer cuatrimestre del año llegarán
progresivamente más de 10 millones de
vacunas compradas a rusia también ha
detallado que la inversión de su
gobierno fue de 200 millones de dólares
crucial ha dado facilidades de pago a
venezuela y el gobierno de maduro
consiguió recursos para obtener ese
primer lote en el primer trimestre del
año las sanciones impuestas por eeuu que
le impide al gobierno acceder a recursos
que tiene en el extranjero lo ha llevado
a acudir a sus aliados para obtener
acuerdos y financiamiento
herminia hay algún tipo de conversación
de negociación entre el gobierno de
nicolás maduro y juan guaidó para poder
adquirir vacunas mediante este mecanismo
internacional kóvacs venezuela podrá
acceder a ellos
si funcionario del gobierno venezolano y
líderes de la oposición se están
reuniendo para discutir un acuerdo que
contempla la compra de vacunas a través
del programa de vacunación kóvacs
utilizando efectivo congelado en eeuu
el líder opositor guango aído ha dicho
que los fondos venezolanos controlados
por el departamento del tesoro de eeuu
podrían usarse para pagar las vacunas
juan guaidó uno de los líderes
opositores de oposición reconocido por
decenas de países incluido eeuu como
presidente interino de venezuela es
quien está autorizada para utilizar los
recursos de venezuela en el extranjero
la reunión entre el gobierno y
opositores marca un paso adelante en lo
que probablemente será un largo proceso
que requerirá que las autoridades
estadounidenses aprueben el uso de los
fondos congelados así como la
finalización de un plan de
implementación de vacunación para
venezuela sumergida en una grave crisis
económica y humanitaria termina gracias
por este reporte desde la ciudad de
caracas continuamos nuestra ronda nos
vamos hasta centroamérica los casi siete
millones de salvadoreños también están
esperando pacientemente ser vacunados
ahora qué
han sido allí puestos en marcha todas
las baterías para el plan de vacunación
un primer lote arribo al aeropuerto
internacional de san salvador y
prácticamente de inmediato fueron
dispuestas para ser inyectadas en las
personas que trabajan en la primera fase
de inoculación que están de cara al
virus de coronavirus el presidente del
ifo que le dio más detalles sobre este
ambicioso plan que espera recibir 2
millones de dosis solo en el primer
trimestre del año
estas 20.000 van a ser luego va a seguir
luego un siguiente pedido también de
astrazéneca también proveniente de la
india de 90.000 luego de eso viene esta
parte de un lote de 2 millones de dosis
que nosotros les anunciamos en diciembre
que habíamos negociado con la
farmacéutica está escénica más detalles
desde san salvador con vladimir chamorro
nuestro corresponsal allí en la capital
salvadoreña
vladimir gracias por acompañarnos hoy y
la pregunta obligada cuál es el balance
de esta primera semana de vacunación
esta semana dio inicio la campaña de
inmunización para el personal de primera
línea en el salvador con el ingreso de
un primer lote de 20 mil vacunas contra
el hobby 19 procedente de la india a la
fecha las autoridades aseguran que cerca
de 2000 profesionales de la salud ya
recibieron la primera dosis este lote de
vacunas constituye la primera entrega de
110 mil dosis que el gobierno ha
comprado a las farmacéuticas 3 zénica
sin embargo aún no se ha informado sobre
la fecha de llegada de las 90.000
restantes el ministro de salud ha
explicado que la vacunación se
implementará entre fases inmunizando
primero al personal de primera línea
luego a las personas con enfermedades
crónicas y a mayores de 50 años y por
último a la población entre los 18 y 50
años de edad este refuerzo inmunitario
no será aplicado a las embarazadas y
menores de edad para quienes está
contraindicado las vacunas se están
administrando en lugares dispuestos por
el gobierno para su aplicación a lo
largo del país y se espera que se
suministre en alrededor de dos mil
vacunas diarias
para las personas contempladas en la
primera fase vladimir a algo ha
caracterizado el gobierno salvadoreño
hermetismo no se sabe cuántas dosis
fueron en total cuánto ha costado una
dosis individual por qué
bueno lo único que hasta ahora se ha
informado es que según las proyecciones
del gobierno la inmunización llegará a
más de 4 millones de personas de forma
gradual con la administración de 2 mil
vacunas diarias como te comentaba en 162
puntos distribuidos en todo el país
aunque se espera un aumento progresivo
de la campaña de vacunación
efectivamente hay mucho hermetismo por
parte del gobierno para hablar sobre los
costos de las 20.000 dosis ni el
presidente ni sus funcionarios han
informado el valor de la compra de las
vacunas de astrazéneca tampoco se ha
dado información sobre el tipo de
contrato con la farmacéutica sino que se
han limitado a hacer énfasis en que
estas dosis no son donación del gobierno
de la india sino una compra hecha por el
gobierno salvadoreño también han dicho
que están en negociaciones con otras
farmacéuticas pero sin dar mayores
detalles en detalle y en particular
vladimir cuáles han sido los retos que
ha tenido que enfrentar el gobierno
salvadoreño para este plan de
inmunización
hay muy poca información sobre los
criterios para seleccionar a las
personas que se vacunarán incluso hay
hospitales que tienen hasta el doble de
personal de las dosis disponibles y esto
ha generado controversia pues existen
trabajadores de la salud que han
expresado inconformidad porque en
algunas de las listas de seleccionados
se ha priorizado a empleados
administrativos y no a quienes tienen
contacto directo con pacientes el
personal de salud a nivel nacional tanto
en lo público como en lo privado superan
las 50 mil personas y de momento solo se
cuentan con 20 mil dosis el gobierno ha
anunciado que a principios de marzo
llegaría un donativo del mecanismo
kóvacs para el acceso global a las
vacunas según los datos publicados en el
sitio web de la iniciativa el salvador
sería beneficiado con 324 mil dosis de
la vacuna astrazéneca y 51 mil 480 dosis
de la farmacéutica pfiezer mantener la
cadena de frío ha sido planteado como un
desafío por expertos en la materia pero
el gobierno asegura que cuenta con el
equipo para mantener la temperatura
adecuada para ambas vacunas así como las
condiciones de logísticas para el manejo
de las mismas
al inicio de la pandemia vimos al
salvador e implementar unas medidas muy
rigurosas el país se aisló muy rápido
cerró las fronteras le negó la entrada a
personas desde el extranjero cómo está
la situación ahora en el país qué
medidas mantienen para hacer frente a la
pandemia en el salvador
pues mira a la fecha el ministerio de
salud registra poco más de 58 mil casos
confirmados de kobe 19 de los cuales se
han recuperado más de 52 mil personas
mientras que alrededor de 3000 se
mantienen activos y se reporta un total
de 1.767 fallecidos a causa del virus el
ministro de salud francisco halabí
confirmó que los contagios presentan una
tendencia sostenida a la baja asimismo
muchos de los casos detectados son
asintomáticos por lo que son tratados
con el kit de medicamentos y vitaminas
que el gobierno entrega de forma
gratuita para la recuperación en casa no
obstante las cifras provistas por el
gobierno el colegio médico que es la
gremial médica más grande del país
continúa insistiendo en la existencia de
un subregistro ya que las inhumaciones
de personas sospechosas de kobe que han
sido reportadas por las municipalidades
es mucho mayor a las cifras de muertes
indicadas por el gobierno hasta
noviembre del año pasado las alcaldías
reportaban al menos 1.800 personas
fallecidas por kobe 19 cifra aproximada
a la que maneja el gobierno sin embargo
también registran más de 3700 personas
fallecidas con sospechas de kobe
1300 innovaciones con diagnóstico de
neumonía atípica lo que supera las
cifras oficiales en más de 4.000
fallecidos
vladimir chamorro actualizándonos de la
situación en el salvador gracias por
este reporte de vladimir y ya lo
mencionábamos pese a haber comenzado
relativamente tarde si se le compara con
otros países chile comenzó a vacunar a
toda velocidad hoy lidera la
inmunización en américa latina es el
sexto país de más de un millón de
habitantes en el mundo que más dosis per
cápita ha suministrado a sus ciudadanos
según el conteo que hace a world in that
a chile ha inoculado a 2.3 millones de
dosis de la vacuna sinovac elaborada en
china el proceso ha sido aplaudido a
nivel internacional pero su meta es muy
ambiciosa alcanzan o pretenden llegar a
más del 80 por ciento de la población
teniendo en cuenta que tiene 19 millones
de habitantes todo esto para el primer
semestre del año 2021
y la remota isla de pascua precisamente
en chile a unos 3.700 kilómetros de la
costa chilena comenzó también su plan de
vacunación esta isla es muy remota y
presenta 0 casos de contagio de kobe 19
gracias a que el territorio fue cerrado
fue aislado cancelaron los vuelos
comerciales cerrando por completo la
industria turística que es el motor
económico de esta isla vamos a conocer
detalles de cómo está avanzando allí el
plan de vacunación y cómo hicieron
frente a esta emergencia está con
nosotros pedro edmunds paoa él es el
alcalde de rapa nui o isla de pascua y
está con nosotros desde agarró a la
capital de la isla y ahora nada señor
alcalde gracias por atendernos allí en
la capital de la isla de pasco y cómo
está avanzando el proceso de vacunación
allí en esta isla remota en la mitad del
pacífico
santiago efectivamente no se nos estamos
inoculando en un promedio de 120 150
personas diarias e iniciamos el 4 de
febrero perdón el 8 de febrero con la
vacunación y a la fecha de hoy llevamos
a sobre 2.000 mil 200 personas vacunadas
y necesitamos llegar a inocular el cien
por cien que serían ocho mil personas
con ese régimen de vacunación y
llegaremos hasta fines del primer
semestre fines de julio o principios de
agosto probablemente con vacunación eso
lo que le puedo comunicar señor alcalde
allí en la isla de paz que ustedes no
han reportado ningún caso de kobe 10 y
90 casos hasta el momento es algo
completamente admirable cuáles fueron
las medidas que ustedes implementaron
allí más allá del simple aislamiento
natural que tiene esta isla
a más de tres mil kilómetros de
distancia del continente americano
efectivamente santiago nuestra crítica
es la poca comunicación
de esta logística nacional que el
presidente de la república ha llevado en
adelante claramente a nivel nacional y
muchos alcaldes estamos en desacuerdo
con la forma como él ha organizado esta
lógica muy muy ensimismado muy a la
ingeniería que solamente él maneja y en
lugares aislados como el nuestro y hay
muchos otros lugares aislados del país
consideran la misma forma de distribuir
como que si fuera en la metrópolis y eso
ya es una visión pegada en una visión de
poca animosidad hacia lugares especiales
lugares con culturas milenarias
especiales y lugares aislados como la
nuestra y se fue básicamente mi crítica
pero ya ha pasado la semana y
rápidamente me contacte con el ministro
de salud y el ministro de salud como que
entendió la situación nuestra y nos está
dando el pase para que se ocupe y se use
el criterio local señor alcalde la isla
ya va a cumplir prácticamente un año
cerrada al turismo que es la industria
más importante el motor económico de
esta isla como se han mantenido a flote
económicamente y cuando piensan volver a
abrir la isla
déjame desarrollar la pregunta con la
siguiente respuesta el pueblo rapanui es
un pueblo milenario tiene una cultura
milenaria polín está donde saben los
embates de la vida y saben muy bien
podemos sobrevivir cuando es amenazada
por por eventual eventos de la
naturaleza y en este caso un caso
pandémico la rapa nui no es indiferente
a hechos históricos que ha amenazado a
la población y es por eso que en su adn
ha aprendido a y ha entendido a poner al
frente conceptos de recuerdo una de
ellas es el tajo el tapón es una orden
sagrada a obedecer disciplinarse
resguardarse y no exaltarse sino que
entender de que esto es un peligro y por
lo tanto
y protegerse cuidarse y esperar el
tiempo necesario pero además
incorporamos para la sustentabilidad 24
centros importantes más uno es el manga
y quiere decir si yo tengo duro te ayudo
y entre los dos ayudamos a un tercero y
así vamos ayudando entre todos nosotros
a sustentar eso se llama su manga que es
un concepto muy antiguo político de
colaboración y el tercer concepto es el
moda y moa significa yo te respeto tú me
respetas respetemos entonces el estado
pandémico que vivimos porque el peligro
no es el del perdón es nuestro enemigo y
a ese enemigo hay que enfocarlo y hay
que mirarlo de frente y no descuidarse
pedro para o alcalde de la isla de
pascua muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros aquí en france 24 en
nuestra sección en redes veamos otras
noticias destacadas de la semana aquí en
kobe 19 comenzamos en la república
dominicana en donde este diario local de
este país titula avanza el plan de
vacunación del personal de salud de la
república dominicana el plan ya fue
extendido a varias zonas del gran santo
domingo la capital y de otras regiones
como hato mayor y el seibo que están en
el este del país y dajabón en la
frontera con haití también en nuestra
página web france24 puntocom tenemos la
onu denuncia que 10 países han acaparado
el 75 por ciento de las vacunas contra
el jove 19 así lo anunció el secretario
general de las naciones unidas antonio
guterres quien calificó la distribución
de tremendamente desigual e injusta y
también señaló que son israel los
emiratos árabes unidos el reino unido y
la unión europea de los territorios
donde se ha concentrado la mayor
cantidad de vacunas todos ellos países
desarrollados y finalizamos con este
artículo también de france 24 punto com
el director general de la omct edrosa
a título no hagan que este virus sea
político la pandemia debería unirnos el
secretario también pidió mayor respaldo
económico para la estrategia kóvacs y
que más personas levanten sus voces en
defensa de la equidad y la unión para
superar la crisis del cob el 19
y así llegamos al final de kobe 19 la
semana en américa nos volvemos a
encontrar la próxima semana sigan
cuidando de el coronavirus la emergencia
continúa sigan con france 24
[Música]